check it out it's the newest casino that
will soon shine bright and it's not on
the las vegas strip you can see how the
construction is quickly coming together
for the next for next year's grand
opening and of course we're talking
about station casino's latest project
called durango casino thank you so much
for staying with us here at 4 30 i'm
christian casadis and i'm kirsten joyce
the resort sits on about 70 acres at
durango drive in the 215 southern
beltway today we're getting a bit of a
different look a bird's eye view at what
nevadans can expect
[Applause]
we're so excited
with the station casino opening up
it's just going to bring more traffic to
the area bahaduri mazadet says he can't
wait until the new durango casino across
the street from his business opens he
hopes the spotlight on the new property
will help get more customers to explore
the southwest valley when we first
opened up there was
there was probably three stores that was
in the shopping center that were open
and then
ikea opened up and ikea gave it a nice
little boost
construction crews for the durango
casino resort off durango drive and the
215 are bustling to get the property
complete
station casinos giving the public a
closer look at the project with this 3d
rendering inside the red rock casino
lobby complete with views of the pool
and the hotel tower in a statement
station casinos tells us the new
property will bring exciting new
amenities and entertainment to our
locals and visitors alike
as the 750 million dollar resort
continues to come together local
residents are split on its impact to the
area on top of its more than one
thousand jobs the property will create
it could be good and bad i feel like
it'll be good for employment but it'll
be bad for a residential area this is a
residential area keep keep the casinos
away from the residential areas keep it
down downtown keep it on the strip a lot
of people moving to las vegas property
value going up obviously a lot of
businesses opening we're very very
excited about everything that's going on
well durango casino is expected to open
in the fall of next year our